on that boat you can see it's it's a
rather large boat even though it was for
divers in in the Red Sea they're sent To
Us by someone who is present who managed
to capture it all on camera the boat
engulfed in flames let's speak to Sky's
Alice Porter
um Alice um what more can you tell us I
understand there has been a statement of
course from the owner as well
yes that's right the Egyptian
authorities say that it was an
electrical short circuit in the boat's
engine room which sparked the fire at
about 6 30 this morning now we know on
board there were 29 people including 15
passengers who were all British now the
owner of the boat has released this
statement it said we do have three
missing British passengers out of 15
passengers and all others reached the
nearest land safely we're now bringing
the boat back to the marina under
Authority supervision still searching
for the three missing passengers now we
don't know the identity of those three
missing passengers but a search party
has been launched and of course this
will be concerning for anyone who has
relatives or family members who are
traveling there at the time and of
course the boat left Port Gallup on
Tuesday and was due to return today
people presumably were sleeping on board
the boat now the Red Sea in Egypt of
course is a very popular destination for
for divers and for Holiday makers and
this could have some quite damaging
impact on the tourist industry but of
course we will bring you updates on this
story as it develops but three British
Nationals are currently missing after a
fire on a boat in the Red Sea